how did you get your first job as a
director / filmmaker how'd I get my
first job my first music video that I
shot on super 16 millimeter was for
up-and-coming a local hip-hop artist
named power man and making long story
short my momentum at Roscoe's and me
working on a lot of music videos I was
like okay I'm ready to direct and I
remember this was like 96 end of 96 that
finally I started my company no I didn't
start my company yet I just started
directing and start my company until 98
but from 96 to 98 I started you know
getting the confidence to you know start
my company and everything with the first
video that I directed on film was a four
artist named Powerman MC and it was a
twelve thousand dollar budget which at
that time for me was a decent budget and
I shot a great video I use my
post-production hookups that I had when
I was working as sin aside so I was able
to incorporate some green screen and
some you know take my directing debut to
you know the best level that I can with
the resources and the people that I knew
that helped me kind of pull that video
off and I was on my way from from that
video I started directing one music
video after the next and yeah being able
to shoot on film and having things look
professional and and at that time it was
very hard to get your hands on film once
you had a real budget because you know
get the rent to film camera I need
someone who knows how to shoot film and
change the pill mags but it was a whole
different filmmaking process and that's
why I really feel good about my journey
because I came from actual family making
background originating my first films on
35-millimeter is it's way different from
shooting on digital cameras now when you
shoot no film you got to get to film you
know develop and then you got to go
through tell us any
and and it takes way more skill to me to
shoot something on 35 millimeter film in
the and then erase up a HD camera and
press the auto settings and you know I
mean think that you're you know making a
movie or whatever which is pretty much
you know what's going on a date these
digital cameras are making everything as
easy as possible to you know acquire
image and it just kind of takes the to
me like the the filmmaking fun out of it
when you know you don't need a light
meter no more you know what I mean like
backing date shooting a film you imagine
the light you measure the distance from
the lens you know to the actor and it's
just different but it's still at the end
of the day all people care about is end
product but as a filmmaker I'm just glad
that I came from you know actual
filmmaking days in transition into the
into the digital world which makes me I
feel like an asset you know to a lot of
different you know productions when I
come to the table I'm able to you know
being you know intelligent across the
whole board when it comes to making a
movie on film or a movie on digital
because some directors are still I
Tarantino I think he's still shooting on
35 millimeter so you know people still
have a love and respect for for a film
but it is still you know it's still a
dying situation that some of us are
trying to keep alive do you remember
your call time on that music video what
was that morning like like 8:00 a.m. it
was aiding him and I remember shooting
most of the video in my neighborhood
because I've lived in my neighborhood
forever and everyone knew me and all the
different uh you know small businesses
and my parents had a nice house on the
corner and I knew a bunch of people with
cars and stuff so I'll pull up a cool
little hip-hop video in like the
neighborhood that came up you know came
up nights for a rap artist and I think
we shot like 12 hours like eight to
eight or something like that which is
you know standard filmmaking hour is
twelve hour days but it was exciting to
shoot my first video on film on an area
sr3 camera crystal scene 24 frames per
second you know
all that good stuff when you're on set
you know you love that you know wow
she's my first actual film it was dope
you